[Musica]
buongiorno io oggi vi parlerò di come un
errore mi ha cambiato la vita
letteralmente in positivo
io lavoro al cern di ginevra al sir di
ginevra diciamo la più grossa
organizzazione di fisica fondamentale
che esiste nel mondo composto all'inizio
da 12 stati membri adesso siamo in 22
quindi tutte l'europa in più c'è anche
israele fondato tra l'altro
dall'italiano tra gli altri edoardo
amaldi proprio con lo scopo di scienze
senza per la pace e noi facciamo fisica
fondamentale pensate siamo circa 5.000
persone che lavorano in maniera
permanente in terza di ginevra 3 mila
dipendenti e 2000 in altro titolo ma 13
mila scienziati ingegneri tecnici da
tutto il mondo vengono a fare
esperimenti
ogni giorno ci sono circa 7 8.000
persone che si affollano si affannano
sul diciamo sul sito per fare questa
cittadella della scienza qualcuno anche
ci dorme anche se sta dei periodi ci
passa il weekend eccetera ma per fare
che cosa
cos'è la siae la scienza e lo scopo per
cui ci siamo
e noi vogliamo capire come siamo evoluti
dal big bang il big bang che tutti
sappiamo e l'inizio della nostra storia
non è solo un esplosione contiene un
sacco di questioni un sacco di domande
per capire come siamo arrivati noi a
esserci oggi al today
per esempio una delle prime questioni è
come mai la materia e antimateria che
per le nostre teorie e anche per quello
che conosciamo è tutto uguale è
perfettamente simmetrica invece
all'inizio c'è stata una sottile
asimmetria che ha pure veramente quasi
subdola che ha permesso noi di esistere
alla materia di vincere la battaglia
solo antimateria e di evolvere fino qui
oggi noi adesso un'altra ancora quasi
non dico più importante su tutti
importanti ma sottile questione è
un'altra rottura di simmetria vedete la
fisica come bella e fatta di simmetria
ma le cose interessanti sono quando si
rompono una rottura di simmetria
ha permesso alle particelle di avere
massa subito all'inizio all'inizio del
big bang le particelle non avevano massa
io non avrei miei 90 kg neanche i vostri
torna il successo qualcosa che si chiama
bosone di higgs di cui poi ritroveremo
parlare e di cui forse avete già sentito
parlare che ha permesso noi tutti di
avere massa quindi noi cerchiamo di
rispondere a queste domande fondamentali
c'è chi si risponde guardando verso
l'infinitamente grande con i grandi
telescopi sono i nostri colleghi amici
astrofisici o cosmologi noi invece
andiamo verso l'infinitamente piccolo
perché l'universo all'inizio era
infinitamente piccolo 14 miliardi di
anni fa quando è nato e andando verso
l'infinitamente piccolo di che cosa
abbiamo bisogno di un super microscopio
pensate lhc quei tubi blu lì che vedete
è un'enorme macchina che sta 100 metri
sotto terra è lunga 27 km quindi e circa
quasi tre volte il tunnel del monte
bianco che ho fatto ieri per venire fino
qui è pieno di alta tecnologia per fare
che cosa
per generare una luce finissima per
poter vedere i cuori vuol dire una luce
che ha un miliardesimo di volte più
piccola dell'atomo e prendiamo l'atomo
facciamo un miliardesimo di volte più
piccola riusciamo a vedere i cuori
eppure ci sembra sempre delle particelle
puntuali senza massa
tutto questo questa altissima questa
altissima tecnologia per generare questa
nuova luce finissima e la luce della
meccanica quantistica
ma vedere vedere non basta vera luce se
qui adesso delle tre c st spegnesse non
mi vede ma anche con la luce ahimè se
qualcuno di voi non avesse gli occhi non
mi vedrebbe per vedere non basta la
supermacchina intanto vedete qui in
altro il tracciato giallo 27 chilometri
in questa piana bellissima di ginevra
dove c'è lago lemano dove c'è il monte
bianco e dove c'è il nostro lhc vedete
lidi nuovi dubbi blu ma ci sono quattro
grandi occhi due sono molto noti sono
atlas e cms sono i due di lato e sono
molto famosi che sono gli occhi che
hanno visto letteralmente il bosone di
higgs di cui poi parleremo
e noi speriamo che questi occhi vedono
oltre del bosone di higgs perché il
bosone di higgs bello come ha chiuso un
libro ma deve aprendo un altro
oggi noi sappiamo che le bosone di higgs
spiega solo il 5 per cento di quello che
esiste del mondo molto poco bisogna
andare più in là è un po alla nostra
summa teologica ma rischia di diventare
anche un po la nostra gabbia la nostra
prigione non vogliamo andare al di là
l'altro ad esempio rivelatore lhcb
quello che vedete in alto è un è un
rivelatore che cerca di studiare proprio
la sottile differenza tra materia
antimateria che ha permesso noi
desistere all'inizio ci stiamo riuscendo
per ora no ve lo dico ma siamo lì per
imparare per apprendere appunto e
torniamo al lhc pensate 27 chilometri di
alta tecnologia
ci sono voluti circa 25 anni per essere
costruito ed è una supermacchina basato
sulla superconduttività non posso
spiegarvi che cos'è questo sarebbe tutto
un altro the dix appunto però è un
fenomeno meraviglioso pensato un filo
elettrico che avete a casa vostra che
porta 5 10 ampere con la
superconduttività porta mille diecimila
bear e senza consumare senza pagare la
bolletta elettrica all'enel senza
consumare è superconduttivo appunto non
dissipa però per fare questo bisogno di
una cosa speciale il cosiddetto super
freddo ha bisogno di frigo speciali che
lo portino almeno 270 gradi di
temperatura e quindi questo bisogno
quindi di un terno speciale che il tubo
blu letteralmente la superiorità il
magnete questi supermagneti che guidano
le particelle sono dentro e il tubo blu
che tra l'altro sapete i primi tubi blu
sono stati fatti qui vicino proprio
schio che il credo sia a 30 km qua di
vicenza
quando ero giovane e appunto venivo a
lavorarci perché ha sostato giovane
anch'io a quando ero giovane mi sono
innamorato di questo fenomeno della
superconduttività ciò cominciato a
lavorare e poi dal diciamo dal 2008
cominciato a lavorare dal professore di
vita di milano all l hc alle prime idee
eccetera e quindi sono venuto diverse
volte qui a schio e per farvi vedere
questo è il primo magnete quel tubo
lui è stato costruito qui a schio quindi
la pelle a torre non la parte di magnete
questo qua il primo magnete
superconduttore che abbiamo fatto per l
xvi sulla base di questo è stato
approvato il progetto
pensate ma dalla costruzione di questo
del 94 del 94 ci sono voluti altri
quindici anni prima che lei la che si
partisse quindi 25 anni in totale di
chianni da randy e poi 15 anni di
costruzione e su tutto con molta
tecnologia italiana gran parte della
krazia è stato costruito tra genova
appunto schio e altre parti e altre
parti d'italia e benissimo siamo partiti
io poi nel 2001 mi hai chiamato tutto è
stata la mia fortuna al cern di ginevra
per dirigere proprio la costruzione
dell'apparato magnetico pensate da solo
vale più della metà del costo della
macchina che era di allora circa 3
miliardi di allora appunto degli anni
duemila
quindi è stato un successo ha avuto un
certo successo nel 2006 abbiamo
completato la costruzione dei magneti e
mi dicono ma resta fa anche
l'interconnessione tra i magneti
l'integrazione mettere assieme vedete è
una cosa molto importante mettere
assieme non è difficile
vedete la complessità un po del mettere
assieme i due magneti vedete qui li due
super tecnici che lo fanno
diciamo tecnicamente meno difficile che
fare ma niente ma il regno della
complessità perché il regno delle
interfacce differenti team differenti
tecnologie devono essere messa si
evenienze difficile ma la gestione della
competizione diversa
mi ricordo ancora 8 settembre 2008 la
partenza successo mondiale google ci
dedicò il simbolo allora allora google
non cambiava il simbolo ogni giorno come
fa adesso lei era sempre solo quello sui
rarissime occasioni lo cambiò cielo
dedicò quel giorno perché funzionalmente
250 giornalisti bender rolfes air
successo mondiale eccetera
due giorni dopo nella mia piacenza sono
piacentino di origine ricevo il premio
forse un po immeritato come cittadini
illustre in conclusione
torno e dico i miei ragazzi e mia moglie
barco diamo su questo premio si sa mai
pensate nove giorni dopo è successo
l'incredibile successo che la macchina
si ferma si ferma perché perché ci fu un
grave guasto proprio
nell'interconnessione non ve lo sto a
fare lunga
anche questo fece la prima sulle pagine
dei giornali e della televisione pensato
l'inter corruzione brucia tutte
l'energia magnetica dentro questi
magneti superconduttori bruciarono due
magneti ma prese 50 magneti questi
magneti pesano 30 tonnellate sono come
un tir carico e li mandò uno contro
l'altro
un disastro incredibile perché non solo
bruciare i due magneti
dell'interconnessione ma ci fu appunto
una serie di danni collaterali
incredibili qualcuno comincia a pensare
chi vogliono 23 anni per riparare forse
non è riparabile
la macchina una debolezza intrinseca si
scatenò il panico si scatenò a questo è
l'errore che ha colpa mia colpa tua
perché quando succede a queste cose poi
il problema di tutti è un po smarcarsi è
umano è umano colpa mia colpa tua
è problema di interfaccia e quindi c'è
sempre
un po come quando in italia vedo succede
un appoggio un'alluvione
per l'amor del cielo bisogna perseguire
che ha fatto degli errori però anti a
volte fin troppo bisogna innanzitutto
rimboccarsi le maniche e io quello che
ho fatto vedendo paese detto ma se
andiamo avanti così finisce più e allora
mi sento ma in fondo chi è responsabile
sono io anche se non ero lì a fare la
cosa è successo un errore ma chi doveva
controllare su dell'ohr chi doveva
mettere in atto tutte le procedure per
intercettare all'errore sono io sono
responsabile e quindi ho preso chiamato
l'agente ho detto ragazzi non
preoccuparti sono il capo della parte
magnetica il responsabile sono io
responsabilità oggettiva innanzitutto ma
anche magari devono aver pensato a tutte
le cose adesso ripariamo poi se devo
andar via vado via
sarà il nuovo merito che veniva anche un
nuovo management false e via e da lì ci
siamo dati da fare questo ha liberato le
energie perché anziché mettersi a dal
problema smarcarsi a trovare un layout e
tutti si sono messi assieme
e lì ho capito veramente dove il noi non
è il contrario del io è l'esaltazione
del lione noi li trova la sua sua vero
vantaggio
grazie ma lasciatemi finire perché qui
sono draconiani con i tempi ma detto che
siete quindi posso permettermi gli
applausi e allora mi dicevo andando così
veramente se l'abbiamo riparato il
solamente un anno e un anno dopo fine
del 2009 l'acceleratore funzionata
umilmente abbiamo capito che quell
errore lei era un sintomo di una
debolezza strutturale che aveva il
nostro acceleratore l'abbiamo riparata
su tutto guardate l'anello la parte
rossa sono i 700 metri letteralmente
disgraziati rovinati
ma abbiamo riparato la parte gialla nera
lo vedete lì in alto a sinistra un po
tutta la macchina e in più siamo
ripartiti lentamente riparando anche
pensando anche ma se succede ancora
qualcosa di simile come evitare i danni
perché vedete quello che abbiamo capito
è che noi eravamo arroganti non
succederà mai invece abbiamo sempre di
no succederà
sbagliare è umano questo come ti
dicevano già i nostri padri latini
sbagliare è umano se metti in conto
l'errore mette anche le barriere
impedisce all'errore di propagarsi a
degenerare troppi danni
umilmente siamo partiti a basso regime
con la macchina non tutto subito a tutto
gas come pensavano di fare l'inizio e
abbiamo avuto il nostro reward il nostro
premio perché abbiamo potuto pensate
solo due anni dopo pensavano di metterci
molto di più
abbiamo potuto chiamare il professor hix
lo vedete repeater il professore inglese
scozzese peter higgs in un
affollatissimo vittoria del serbo
abbiamo potuto fargli vedere lui a tutto
il mondo che avevamo trovato il suo
bosone il mitico bosone
ora sappiamo perché noi tutti abbiamo
una massa che non è proprio poco proprio
da poco persino un giornale come
l'economist normalmente non molto amico
della scienza ci ha dedicato la pagina
diciamo la copertina la nostra fabiola
gianotti che adesso tutti conoscete come
tappa del serd direttrice del serve
allora era responsabile dell'esperimento
atlas quindi lei annunciò il bosone di
higgs diventò una delle cinque persone
di copertine del tanque di quell'anno
cose di cui viene dalla mia università
quindi siamo orgogliosissimi di questo
immediatamente fu dato premio nobel
disponibile primo al pressori e il
professor ingleheart immediatamente
l'anno dopo il primo premio nobel
disponibile quindi una storia a lieto
fine perché abbiamo trovato questo molto
di più perché per me è stata veramente
lieto fine
cosa ci ho guadagnato perché la fine
tutto facciamo per guadagnarsi anche un
santanchè uno che dalla vita lo fa per
un bene superiore è uno quando fa una
cosa devi guadagnarti a un principio di
fisica il principio di minima energia
tutto si fa per guadagnare la natura fa
questo quindi anche quando uno fa un
atto dal turismo è perché pensa di
guadagnare un vero tesoro più importante
di quello che da via e io cosa ci ho
guadagnato bevi di così consegnato
professionalmente guadagnando ancor di
più il carisma autorevolezza e la gente
mi segue il nuovo management anziché a
mandarmi via
ma non da tuning dopo aver riparato nel
carico più importante oggi de rigo il
nuovo progetto bandiera del ser l'ho
proposto nel 2010 e si chiama lhc ad
alta luminosità sono di uno se li comuni
carico più importante con cui finirò la
carriera e in più ci ha guadagnato
umanamente ho imparato che appunto
prendersi le risulta la colpa la cosa
che nessuno vuole scusate se lo dico ma
la colpa un po come la carta appena
fuori nessuno la vuole vuole più toccare
per letteralmente così
[Applauso]
invece siamo ma se uno parte dell'idea
mio sono limitato farò l'errore lo metti
in conto è appunto può partire può farlo
diventare così l'errore lungi
dall'essere una cosa che ti schiaccia
può diventare un come un segnale come un
segnale stradale che ti indica dove
andare e andare meglio
difatti vi dicevo abbiamo capito che
quell errore lì era segno di una
debolezza strutturale che va nella
macchina che sarebbe stato molto più
grave se si rivelava dopo e l'abbiamo
riparata ma l'aver rivelato addirittura
dopo aver trovato bisogno di
completamente l'abbiamo fisica di
riparare nel 2015
quindi se avete siamo emesso cinque anni
completamente ma io ho guadagnato anche
umanamente in quel periodo con mia
moglie via due figli uno il più piccolo
pietro momento che da va male a scuola
fisico
io sono un po pretenzioso ma sono
universitarie cosiddetto ognuno dotati
non solo questo ognuno i suoi difetti e
quindi mi arrabbiavo con lui perché mi
sembrava che non si impegnarci come
spesso capita ai ragazzi ai maschi
eccetera e io lo bastona vaud e poi ho
capito li ha detto ma ragazzi se il mio
capo mi bastona sensi che aiutarmi a
riparare l'errore e da lì ho capito che
uno sguardo diverso positivo non nel
senso che l'errore non va riconosciuto
l'errore l'errore lo sbaglia lo sbaglio
ma lo sbaglio è lì per di carte come
migliorare lo sguardo che serve per il
figlio capito dallo sguardo che serve
verso collega non è diverso io questo
che ci ha guadagnato che un guadagno
morale non è diverso da un guadagno
professionale severo per me come persona
ad essere vero per me anche come fisico
è che io questo che avrei trasmetti
l'errore anzi non bisogna mai farsi
schiacciare dagli sbagli ma capire che
l'errore è lì per indicarti che insieme
non da solo non solo con la tua volontà
ma con uno sguardo insieme la comunità
non è il contrario del io è
l'esaltazione del io e quindi insieme si
può andare avanti l'errore anziché su
una barriera può diventare il sasso su
cui che anziché ser d'inciampo mette il
piede e vai avanti e va ancora più
avanti grazie per l'attenzione
[Applauso]